kelsey ballerini and the brothers
osborne
good to see hello boys because kelsey
we're
we were watching you guys earlier and i
heard kelsey say hello boys and they
said hey
i like what you guys said about some
early morning winging it so
kelsey let's start off with the first
category which is
group of the year who are the nominees
kelsey ballerini
how exciting okay all right y'all acm
group of the year nominees are lady a
yes little big town
old dominion the cadillac three
and the hot women that's a very cool
list all right kelsey you've also got
the list for duo
of the year who are the nominees
yes all right duo of the year brooks and
dunn
dan and shay florida georgia line
maddie and tay and of course
look at that congrats
dj john you guys have been here before
you've won this award twice before how
does it feel to be on the list again
oh it always feels amazing it's
something that you never take for
granted
i'm surprised they actually ever let us
in the room to begin with so
it feels incredible this last for a
second there i was like
i know tj that's one of those moments
where you got to hold your face on
straight oh congratulations to other
nominees
i'm so glad you guys are on the list
that's awesome anthony iron not
surprised
okay casey i mean kelsey sorry um
next is female artist of the year who
are the nominees tj for you
could you read that list please all
right
miranda lamberts yes
ashley mcbride of course
maren morris carly pierce
and our very own kelsey valentine very
own kelsey ballerini
yeah that is such a listen kelsey that
is such a good category
all of you guys are so good but this is
your one two three four
fifth nomination what does that mean to
you i'd like to think it never gets old
oh my gosh it never gets old but i do
have to say
i've known carly pierce for a long time
since we both had anything going on
and this is her first time being
nominated in this category so
i'm excited for me but i think i'm more
excited for her honestly all right let's
move on to male artist of the year tj
you got the
nominees for that all right dirks
bentley
luke combs eric church
thomas rhett and chris stapleton
all right that sounds good the next
category is
single of the year it's awarded to the
song's artist
producer and the record label john
you're up first you're up on that one
who are the nominees all right
i got this the nominees are blue bird
miranda lambert i hope
gabby barrett i hope you're happy now
carly pearce pearson lee bryce more
hearts than mine
ingrid andrus the bones
marin morris wow great song yeah yeah
they're all good songs
kelsey this is the first time in acm
history where all the nominees in that
category or female artists what do you
make of that if anything
uh progress
2021 yes i wouldn't know what it looks
like to be a female in country music
without the females that were
on the radio when i was a little girl so
the fact that that's happening again
is really exciting and all these songs
are so strong so good
all right one of the biggest honors of
course is entertainer of the year
i think john you've got that list of
nominees
i do all right the nominees are luke
bryan
eric church luke combs
thomas rhett and chris stapleton all
right we went from all women
now we have all men are you guys
surprised by that
i mean i i wouldn't say surprised
sadly but you know i think the fact that
we've seen all women in single of the
year
it shows that you know we're getting
there progress is being made let's hope
as the years progress that we'll see
more females in that category i think it
shows maybe that the females put out
better songs than we do
you know what i think is interesting i i
love what you just said kelsey about how
you've had all the nominations and this
is carly's first time
this is what i love about country music
people number one you're so close i
think that you are some of the nicest
people
on the planet in terms of supporting and
cheering each other on
so what's it like though when you read
the category and you're in the same
category but you like
somebody else aren't you still pulling
for yourself sorta kinda
it's like healthy competition right it's
like you want to win but also if someone
else wins you're not going to be
heartbroken because you're also a fan of
them and a friend of them so it's all
good
but it's sure nice winning
kelsey ballerini and the brothers
osborne that's tj and john if you guys
will stay with us we're going to take a
little break
we'll be back because we would like to
continue the discussion